[Music]
it's been super cooperative they might
not even put him in cuffs they might
just sit him in the back yeah you know
what i'm ready to take him to be fair he
has been
pretty chill like he's not making a
scene he's chilling
and you can even understand that not
wanting to take the field sobriety test
because i do understand the you don't
want your kid to have to see that kind
of thing
um but it is a second dui she said
yeah
that's a sweet-ass eagle tattoo though
i wonder what house he is and harry
potter
all right um
putting that [ __ ] sorting hat on
everybody put on his and it says
construction
wait what
i thought it was a hufflepuff nope says
your construction
next hispanic kid comes up carpenter
i want to be a gryffindor carpenter
a [ __ ]
damn it
would be greatly successful as a roofer
what house did what house did you who
joined pedro i don't know they said i
mean lawn care i never heard of that
house
one of them put some one of them puts on
the head chinese food line cook and then
you stumble dumbledore's just using him
as [ __ ] cooks you're right and he's
like and he's like uh excuse me pedro i
expecto my breakfast first thing in the
morning
[Laughter]
get your [ __ ] together before any waves
is one sarcastically i phono
the fedzo
dumbledore's just some racist [ __ ]
[ __ ]
expecto lamigra
oh
you have made it to the most prestigious
house
janitor
helpius cometh
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
me
philosophers
philosophers s stone
mr dumbledore how come they get to fly
on the broom and i have to sweep with it
mr dumbledore we go into chamber of a
secret secret biggest biggest snake eat
miguel
you said a secret but you didn't say a
snake come on i said a snake a snake
okay good biggest snake eater miguel
miamivo says
that they sorted her into the house of
the thing you're lysol to be seeing is
the chamber of linen [ __ ]
expecto community service
uh you don't young
young
young mexican wizards you don't choose
the chunkle the chunklet chooses you oh
[ __ ] god and the prisoners of ice
[Laughter]
ice kavan
and the ch
[ __ ] hold
harry harry potter and the goblin of
harris
[Music]
harry
[Music]
i hid one of the
one of the patronuses in your butt like
clamato
[Music]
herman puerto and the philosopher's a
stone
mexican hogwarts is just in front of a
home depot
instead of actual spells they're doing
santeria
a lot of dead chickens are mexican
hogwarts
oh i went to the back
i went to the back
and it was just dead chickens just
headless
it was the weirdest thing it starts to
smell too you think they'd clean it all
of them being mexican you think it'd be
really clean there
but it's not
because they're too busy doing magic
right right
but it's delivered by a rooster instead
of an owl
[Music]
it's watered up in the center of your
burrito oh
like a fortune cookie
oh [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
okay who made that
i don't know i just found it
[Music]
mexican harry online yes
oh
oh [ __ ]
can harry potter would be chubby era
harry potter and the goblet of tequila
and instead of a train they go to arrive
at mexican hogwarts to go through a
greyhound
a magical rail
you have to get on the bus
[Music]
you have to pay a shady white guy an
absorbent amount of money
and he sneaks you there
what are they called what are they
called
coyotes
and then you do the steam from american
dad and lava de las manos
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm in the house of monte carlo
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ]
all right we're done come on man you
guys are stupid why did you so stupid
who you mean started that joke
um harry potter and the order my
groceries go in problem
oh [ __ ] um
oh god
oh no a.m is calling calling harry
potter um the mexican harry potter juan
terracotta
[Music]
oh harry potter in the chamber of
dependence
uh
all right come on enough guys all right
ready
moving on yeah well you guys you guys
forgot about the spin-off fantastic
chorizo and where to find it no that's
not
funny come on man that's not nice
how about harry potter in the order of
the university of phoenix
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] that killed me
how about harry potter and the half
blood [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] dexa leviosa
all right we're done now
enough
okay
harry potter and the goblet of clamato
now we're done um now we're done now
we're really done okay we're done no
more
we should have just going harry potter
and the whimsical lawnmower okay stop
look listen
enough hot takes we've had enough hot
takes
that's it enough no more we have no more
hot tanks
oh no green lobster he would be part of
house depot
[Music]
oh
god that joke was right under here
[Music]
when guardian levy you missed the spot
oh
no no mr voldemort no home
[Music]
oh jesus
i cannot believe that there is a
mariachi cover
of the harry potter theme and not only
is it really good but it only has 900
views it should have more oh my god it
was just put up last month this was
meant to be
this entire thing was meant to be
there's a link by the way give it some
love hi rumble peepees here's the link
well let me fight some donations to get
out of here we ain't topping that so i'm
not even gonna [ __ ] try
i'm not even gonna [ __ ] try
stop trying
chester ludlow jr super chatted five
dollars my grandmother died 20 years ago
do i have do i have an n pass you always
did
you always did
[Music]
um
what did i say sorry that was must have
been under the three let me read it
a
prometheus [ __ ]
i mean that must have made sense at some
point but we've moved so fast here you
know what you know what
hey my favorite character of mexican
harry potter was as servious as snape